pido un poco de contexto para empezar
Por qué Y cómo llega lazo a tomar esta
decisión de disolver El parlamento
y buenas Cómo están creo que el contexto
es importante para este tipo de
decisiones Porque desde
el presidente lazo
ha tenido una fuerte oposición Desde la
asamblea por parte del partido social
cristiano que es la derecha tradicional
y la revolución ciudadana que es el
partido del expresidente Rafael correa
antes de asumir la presidencia el
presidente lazo y su Bloque
parlamentario negoció con estas dos
fuerzas y casi estaba listo el acuerdo
sin embargo debido a la oposición más
que nada de del de la gente que la gente
salió a criticar este este pacto esta
Alianza lazo rompió la alianza con ellos
antes de concretarla Y subió al gobierno
solo apoyado por unas fuerzas más bien
de centro y de Centro izquierda como
izquierda democrática Y pachacúl a lo
largo de los dos años ha habido varios
intentos de llevarlo a juicio de hacer
la muerte Cruzada por parte del
parlamento porque el parlamento también
puede destituir al presidente en el
primer año de gobierno
y esta segunda vez es por se le inició
un juicio político el juicio político
carece de digamos algunos sustentos como
por ejemplo que la acusación se ha
cambiado varias veces en el camino no se
ha cumplido con ciertos procesos se está
acusando el presidente de peculado por
omisión un delito que no existe en el en
la legislación ecuatoriana Y entonces es
bastante problemática esta acusación Por
decirlo menos es bastante problemática
porque la acusación es porque se firmó
un contrato en el 2018 antes de que él
fuera presidente y ese contrato se ha
seguido cumpliendo y cuando se dijo que
podría haber corrupción en ese contrato
este todavía ese contrato continúa
porque legalmente no se le puede dar de
baja todavía a ese contrato Esa es la
eso es lo de fondo es un contrato de
comercialización de petróleo Entonces
por esto por este dado por omisión se lo
quiere destituir y la otra cosa es que
claro ha habido todo casi estos dos años
desde mayo 2021 Hasta ahora ha habido
esta crisis política porque no no ha
podido ser posible que las fuerzas
políticas encuentren un digamos
un sentido común un objetivo común para
poder aprobar ciertas leyes Sí entonces
Bueno disculpe que no tenemos mucho
tiempo pero a raíz de lo que usted está
planteando hay una duda que me surge Y
seguramente a gran parte de nuestra
audiencia Y es que sí como usted Comenta
este juicio político carece de ciertos
sustentos porque laso decide
renunciar disolver el parlamento y
también acabar con su mandato y la
oposición critica esta esta decisión
Cómo se lee el escenario actual hay que
tener la oposición no es una sola la
posición son básicamente dos partidos el
uno que es el tradicional de derecha
social cristiano que critica la decisión
pero en cambio la revolución ciudadana
el partido de Rafael Correa no ha
criticado la la la decisión ellos más
bien apoyaron la la muerte Cruzada
porque consideran que seguramente el
momento que el lazo termina su periodo
va a haber nuevas elecciones lazo va a
terminar gobernando seis meses hasta que
existan nuevas elecciones y se declare
nuevo ganador yo no creo que él vaya a
ganar la presidencia otra vez
definitivamente no entonces va a haber
un nuevo actor que va a irrumpir y una
nueva asamblea y es solo para el período
que resta por venir significa que solo
por dos años Esa es la Norma y entonces
la revolución un ciudadano el partido de
Rafael Correa está de acuerdo con la la
muerte Cruzada por lo menos eso es hasta
eso es lo que
lo lo que se esperaba porque ellos
piensan que ellos van a ganar yo creo
que la revolución ciudadana piensa que
como le fue bien en las elecciones
seccionales que son elecciones de medio
periodo que no se cambia cámara no se
cambia se cambian solo alcaldías y
prefecturas ellos ellos les fue muy bien
en estas elecciones Entonces ellos
piensan que ellos van a ganar la
presidencia y van a volver a tener
mayoría en la asamblea lo social
cristianos que están disminuidos porque
Perdieron su clase principal en
guayas para ellos no para ellos la
muerte Cruzada no les conviene tanto
pero ellos eran los principales
impulsores de este juicio político